This is our new orphanage?
It's as big as a castle!
Feel free to use the house as you see fit.
Misses Mullins and I will stay down here.
Your rooms are upstairs.
Locked...
and it stays that way.
(you are my sunshine, my only sunshine, you make me happy when... )
You're the monster, are you?
Can you help me?
Ahhh!!!
Janice says she's seen your daughter
My daughter has been dead for a very long time.
She was taken from us at an early age.
Nooooo!!!
We prayed to see our beloved girl again.
The contact started small,
but then it wanted permission to move into a doll,
so it can be with us forever.
We said yes.
Ahhh!!!!
Sister. It's coming after me.
Who? An evil presence.
It's because I'm the weakest.
It's the doll.
The devil.
Annabelle!?